I still got a few years left in me for
sure so I want to prove to love and how
much you can do even with something like
this
you read a letter from the concrete iver
association just saying about how
they're all in sport of for me for the
future now their support me and my
recovery I saw a letter at the front for
our that's that's amazing and there's a
turnover and there be signatures from
many world champions
Lewis Hamilton Niki Lauda that really
touch martyr these are look like some of
the names on here and they're my hero so
yeah I was lost for words and I was down
now I think we started off in that
different warden now we're in the major
trauma ward yes I've been for a fair few
of the staff here and they've all lived
up to high expectations it's been truly
inspiring to see how supportive they are
horrible they're part of all the
patients but just me what without them I
wouldn't be here today sigh a massive
thanks to every single one of the staff
they've helped me yeah and it's going to
be emotional Sangha by two more